am i a serious dancer
i don't know
is a heart attack serious
a lot of people like to ask me a lot of
questions like did i single-handedly
change the face of hip-hop itself
is oxygen important to life on earth
let's not ask stupid questions okay like
why would you even ask why why is
abraham lincoln's face
on the 100 bill why
do the aliens build the grand canyon
these are the mysteries of life
no one has answers
when i first started dancing uh i
originally didn't start off by myself
because the story of company dumpty is
interesting i started off with a group
of kids it was me and them um
i was an early bloomer so uh i was a
little bit bigger than they were so i'm
roughly about the same size as i was
then
as i am now i don't think they enjoyed
the fact that i was a little bit larger
than them
okay that i could do certain things that
they couldn't do i was i was the best i
was crumpty dumpty at this time i wasn't
crumpy dumpty though uh i started off my
new alias as tickle me elbow and they
were mad because they couldn't make uh a
new name for themselves and they wanted
to go ahead and start off another crew
called the art of technique
they even misspelled technique that's
how stupid they are
we were known as uh the dancing
intelligent cool kids
dicks
the problem with that was is that i was
the biggest dick of all they didn't like
that i was the biggest dick
when other big dicks battled little
dicks
there was a lot of turmoil it got to
fist fights
later on
they started developing up dance
routines without me they didn't like the
fact that i was shining that i was doing
a little bit better than them
did i regret some of the things that i
said
you're racist
it's a race thing because i'm the
light-skinned one in the group that's
the problem
i'm not saying that you're done
no
i said what i said because i meant it at
the time and you know what i still stand
by today what is that
right
that's the real question what is dance
dance is more of a
of a technique it's an art it's the art
of illusion am i a dancer more or less
i'm a magician right am i a tree
am i a part of the tree
so you want to think about these
different things when you become a
dancer right
let's describe me
as a basketball player who would i be i
would be a mix of michael jordan
and jesus and that's the thing about me
i wanted to branch off i didn't want to
be confined in that small little sardine
camp they called dance i wanted to break
free develop my own move basically
this is how comfy dumpy started off